[Music]
absolutely
[Applause]
[Music]
uh what a lad and you won't be surprised
that again I have another absolute lad
for you for this one today's guest is
one of the best referees in the game a
man who has been in charge of
controlling some of the biggest
International games there are and he is
just genuinely a really good lad who's
open to sharing what life is really like
as a pro ref this is one that I've been
really looking forward to it is with the
legend himself Paul Williams welcome
mate oh awesome mate Jimmy thanks for
being here it's a pleasure mate awesome
to have you on
um a lot of people probably won't know
but you're a part of I guess the
Crusaders at the moment all the refs
have been given a franchise so a managed
to rope you into a podcast while you've
been here yeah I thought he probably
would line me up at some stage I've been
trying to avoid you like playing but uh
unfortunately you've got me you've
nailed me down here I am well you're
here and ready to share that's the one
and have a beer by the way how good um
10 30 in the morning having a very
Summit Ultra hey well it is Easter and
we should be celebrating so Cheers
Cheers appreciate it
but let's start with it um 2023
um refereeing Super Rugby some new rules
uh I guess the game's change I feel like
refereeing's at some of the best level
it's been for a while I feel like the
refs have stayed well out of the news
this season you will long long way that
last day yeah um yeah it's pretty good
at the moment
um I think I think there's a couple of
reasons behind that you know um
obviously the Innovations of the game
has meant that this far less TMO
involvement so that's obviously a good
thing
um which has then put a lot of
responsibility back on the shoulders of
the the team of three that's on the
ground
which is actually really nice and I
think too like the fact that coaches and
players know that the Teemo will only be
coming in for those really big moments
those really big mistakes that we make
um probably gives everyone a lot of
confidence that we're going to see a lot
more ball on play which we clearly have
I mean the stats of um have shown a
higher percentage of ball and play
you know I was looking at more running
figures the other day and I did the
Hurricanes force game and did 10.2 K in
that game bro what would you usually do
how does that compare yeah well look in
in previous Years Gone by I mean it kind
of depends on what game you're referring
what competition
um Super Rugby is naturally pretty fast
so on average I'll probably be doing
somewhere around
you know eight eight to nine K and
that's that's that's quite High
typically but now we're seeing it well
over um the nines and up into the tens
so you know that's um it's great for the
game it's great for those sitting at
home on the couch but tell your watch is
pretty hard work on my little legs mate
yeah yeah a little bit more time in the
gym a little bit more speed and fitness
work I think yeah so how does that
affect does that affect the decision
making obviously when you come under
fatigue or not really is that why it's
so important to be fit well well
naturally it does you know we don't have
the privilege um we don't have the
luxury I should say of um you know
subbing someone else in with 20 to go
you know so we've obviously got to make
sure we're with cardiovascular fit yeah
um but also ready for those fast high
intensity movements as well so
um yeah yeah I mean I think a lot of
people would be surprised about the
amount of work we actually have to do
physically
um because you know you think Super
Rugby gets to a point where you know it
can't get much faster but yet again we
find ways to make it quicker so which is
great as a spectacle but it just means
we have to work that a little bit harder
away from the game yeah I've never
really thought about that so as the last
sort of 20 minutes 10 minutes of the
game the hardest for you to referee
um I wouldn't say it's the hardest I
mean you could have a kickoff and have a
really high impact decision um in the
first sort of collision of the game
um but it's all kind of relative you
know you put it in context uh score
whether the occasion the crowd all that
stuff sort of contributes to that
pressure
um so yeah I think well I don't think I
know that if you can totally manage that
your physical pillar as well as yet that
mental pillar which we know now is
critical
um it puts you in a really good place to
be able to make those big decisions
right at the end of the game and we'd
love that too you know like it's the
same as a play you know when they've got
to make that clutch kick from the
sideline yeah we love that pressure we
love being in the moment so um yeah yeah
it's I think it'd be similar to a play
you know we love those type games
because those are ones where you really
have to work yeah true so those games
where it's like drawn full time 80
minutes is up you'd love that moment I
always felt like as a referee you'd be
trying to avoid those moments and avoid
those big calls because at the end of
the day yeah it's probably going to come
down or you're going to be in the news
again around you're cool with it was
right or wrong because there's so many
so many gray areas in the game still
which you know you could look at someone
entering a breakdown and you could call
probably three or four penalties on just
one breakdown yeah yeah absolutely
um no I think I can probably
speak on behalf of most referees and say
we we love those big moments we love
those close games and and getting drawn
in and it's funny you say that because
um I remember vividly uh the game
Australia and New Zealand Australia it
was during covert times and we were uh
we weren't able to have uh Mutual
referees first ever after referee well
no no I'll correct you there was a
second one oh yeah yeah it had been 50
years since um since the first one so um
it was a pretty like the whole occasion
was a bizarre sort of um uh experience
so you know traveling to the ground
normally would be somewhere else you
know would be refereeing test matches
elsewhere where there's a test match on
at home would be watching it in the
early hours of the morning
um so anyway driving driving to the
ground it was at Westpac trust Stadium
Sky Stadium now apologies uh driving to
the stadium and you know you've got all
black supporters walking along the
street and I'm looking at the one day
going this doesn't feel right yeah you
know this is odd this is weird
um and then once we got to the stadium
and you just go about your normal
process your warm up and all the rest of
it so that was fine
but then one thing I hadn't really
affected in was how I would be feeling
when I stood in front of the grandstand
listening to the national anthem yeah so
naturally the Australians did these
first and that was Florence I've heard
that plenty of time standing in the
middle
but then when the all black sorry with
the the New Zealand national anthem
started I really choked up true really
choked up and I was fighting back the
tears
um and I had no idea that the emotion
was going to hit me like it had
in any way like I didn't even remember
the the Haka so I'm still processing
trying to get myself under control
before kickoff you know so I don't
remember the Haka at all but as soon as
I blew the whistle I was like right I'm
into this now you know that was like the
trigger of park there I've dealt with it
I took a few deep breaths obviously
beforehand but but then I was into the
game
and you know I'm a pretty simple guy
like I can't factor in you know
favoritism of the All Blacks or anything
like that boy so I'm just not that smart
you know like I'm running around going
here's the decision here's a play on you
know yeah in the moment
but um I'll vividly remember the end of
that game and I'm sure a lot of your
viewers do as well that
um it was a it was a draw I mean the
game ended up being a draw but the last
play of the game uh Rhys Hodge had a
penalty shot at Gold the moments you
love you you awarded that one wow
um you know again I was in the moment I
just saw a decision that had to be made
and I blew the penalty yeah it wasn't
until after I blew the blue the penalty
and I looked to Michael Hooper to see
what he wanted to do and he pointed to
the shots I've pointed to the post for a
shot and then it dawned on me I was like
holy hell yeah I could be refereeing the
All Blacks to a lot yeah I'm gonna have
to move home I'm gonna have to leave the
country
um so as he's lining up the shot like
all of these sort of um childhood
memories are flooding back oh yeah and I
knew like the way Rhys Hodge kicks a
ball like that's either going to go
through the post or it's going to go
like down Cuba Street distance was not
going to be a problem for him and
generally outstand about the middle of
the field and follow the ball in but I
was like if this is going over I need to
see this so I got very close to actually
track the ball going towards the posts
and you know I kicker as he kicks it you
know when he's had it sweetly right and
this thing is just absolutely humming
towards the post and then I don't know
what it was but it must have been a like
at the hand of God or something but at
the very last second it broke right
smacked into the post and now the game's
back on again and I'm like so in that
moment and it was probably a really good
learning opportunity for me too like in
that moment like my mind was going back
to like me as a young boy doing the Haka
butt naked in my room in front of the
mirror you know and giving it the big
ones and you know the early mornings
where you're watching the All Blacks and
all this sort of stuff's coming back
so in that moment I my mind was
elsewhere and then when the ball hit the
post I was like wow I've got to get back
into this game here yeah and you know on
reflection I wasn't able to pick up on
it sort of the the days or even the
weeks after that because it was all
still quite Raw
but after afterwards I was like you know
it probably took me a good 20 to 30
seconds to pull myself back from all
that external thinking and get back
focused into you know here's a pass he's
a tech or has he rolled away all that
sort of stuff and I'll freely admit like
there were decisions there like both
ways against the ball blacks for the All
Blacks for Australia against Australia
that I just wasn't in the zone you know
yeah
um and the game ended up going for an
extra eight minutes that's right and I
was just like you know and the crowd was
on their feet for those eight minutes it
was raining and it was you know it was
one of those moments that we spoke about
before that you know you love that as a
referee and you know those are the games
you remember the ones where it's a
blowout and yeah you know it's um you
know you don't get drawn into it that
much you don't remember those games but
yeah man I've got some very very Vivid
memories of that game yeah it's cool it
sounds like an absolute emotional
rollercoaster it was it was it took me a
couple of weeks to sort of get myself
under control after that one but uh oh
look at was um it was a pleasure to be
able to
um say that of referee the All Blacks
because I mean when I started out in
this career like it was never possible
um but I'll tell you what I hope it
never happens again yeah really yeah I'm
quite happy to stay well away from the
All Blacks like uh
um like I said before I don't think I'm
I'm intelligent enough to have any bias
one way or the other
um but yeah I just think the all the
external noise and the possible
perception that might be out there I
think it's best if you know if
countrymen stay away from referring
their own country absolutely yeah and
the World Cup this year it's even going
a step further isn't it in terms of you
can't referee someone in the same pool
yeah I believe that's right yeah yeah
which makes sense right yeah because of
that because of that external fact that
you might want to try and get them
through yeah yeah oh I mean yeah again
that's that's all perception based right
right we're we're professionals and what
we do we we make decisions based on the
pictures that present this present
themselves
um you know to be able to it's hard
enough
to do that you know like you said before
you go to a breakdown there could be
five or six decisions but you've got to
choose the best one yeah like to layer
over the top of that who's from what
country or players or the rest of it
we're just not good enough to do that
you know so yeah yeah it's such a hard
game to referee though isn't it it is
like it is
um yeah there's no doubt we've got a
very um complex game
um you know and we're only trying to
find ways like changing the laws to to
make it a more entertaining spectacle
which I'm hugely in favor for but
um yeah it takes quite a bit of uh
mental elasticity each season to
actually get your head around these
different sorts of law variations and
whatnot
um you know and even within a season and
within a year it can be different in
different competitions so yeah it's not
easy for us I mean it's not even easy
for the punter sitting at home either so
but you know I think we're certainly on
the right path in terms of
um creating a product that everyone can
understand anyway yeah a little way to
go yeah yeah so I'm interested into how
you sort of got into refereeing as well
like obviously a young taranaki Lair
grew up
on the coast here of the beautiful North
Island
um yeah yeah yeah I'm very very
privileged and blessed for for my
upbringing um so I grew up in a little
place called uh uh partia I was actually
uh puenocura um a little rural community
in between party and Waverly same as
Elijah Taylor that's the one mate yeah
they've breed some good stuff
um so uh yeah yeah that was I came from
pretty humble upbrings you know on the
farm
um entertainment on the weekend was
obviously rugby but then after rugby hot
pie and a coke at the bottom Dairy then
home to do some healing or motorbike
riding or whatever it was or it might be
time to go and get the cows and so yeah
it was a pretty simple simple upbringing
but um yeah look uh I'll probably follow
the natural pathway in terms of most
young guys at that stage and off to off
to school boarding school up at Francis
Douglas
um a lot of my years up there I really
really grew as a young lad there I think
a lot of good players came out of there
too yeah
[Music]
a couple of names at ring a bell plus a
few others so uh yeah unfortunately I
wasn't on the all black list but I tried
to find another Avenue so
um but yeah I guess uh for refereeing it
was 2011. um I was over in the UK at the
time obviously 2011 was when we had the
World Cup and I really wanted to be
involved in that in some way shape or
form obviously I wasn't going to be
involved as a player yeah so I thought
hey how about being a volunteer
so I applied for a job as a player as a
team liaison and I thought you know what
better way to sort of be involved in the
World Cup than to be with a team and
cruise around New Zealand
anyway the guy who was interviewing me
was a guy called um Ray Hopkins and he
was the uh president of the local
referees Association I knew him very
well uh he knew that I played Club rugby
back in taranaki and he said to me um at
the end of the interview you know Paul
have you ever thought about giving
refereeing a go
and in my head I was like hell no I've
never thought about that because I was
that Lippy little halfback that used to
give referees heaps on the field but
then I thought you know if I say no it's
probably not going to do my chances and
you've got to getting this job so I said
to him actually you know what yeah I
might give it a go one date it's a
really good thought
um and I really shot myself on the foot
because two weeks later I was rippering
in under 12's game down in Harrah before
playing Prim footy in the afternoon so
that was 2011 fast forward to 2015 and
New Zealand Rugby offered me a full-time
contract all right that's quirky yeah
yeah it was pretty quick um I was
probably pretty fortunate too because it
was the same year
um actually I think the start of 2016
was when the Super Rugby competition
expanded to Super 18. which was great
but we had a shortage of referees so we
had to pull a few in so I was one of the
lucky ones it was myself Brendan
Pickerel and uh what led Jamie nut brown
oh yeah
um so yeah the three of us got a cracker
um joining the Super Rugby panel and we
were into it um but gee I remember
getting that contract going
Play Hell these guys are going to pay me
to run around and blow whistle are they
right in the here
um but yeah no it's uh it's been a hell
of a journey May Day and um you know the
skills and
um you know like I guess personal skills
that I've picked up through being
involved in such a high pressure job
um have been so transferable in other
areas of my life you know and I think
you know we were talking the other day
about the the level of resilience that
it builds up within you as a person you
know week in week out you're constantly
in the spotlight
um so to be able to manage 30 guys in a
high pressure environment you've got to
be really in check with yourself you
know you need to be able to manage
yourself and if you can't do that then
good luck you know you'll be battling
but um you know now it's sort of got to
a place where managing 30 big Burly
blokes on the field is easy going home
and managing three kids bloody hell now
that's tough work eh
um but yeah that's kind of how the
journey started mate and how I got onto
it and sort of where I am now yeah so
did you love it from the start like that
first game under 12 whatever it was did
yeah did you love it did you love the
feeling of having the Whistle the
control or oh yeah probably I think more
so
um it really lined up with one or more
values which is around contribution and
um you know I've got some these I won't
say the end of my playing career because
you know I was only about 27 loving my
footy yeah loving my footy fortunate
enough not to be injured or anything
like that I was playing for southern at
the time great bunch of leads
um and then this opportunity came up and
um you know I was really reluctant about
taking that jump uh into profit it
wasn't professional then but taking that
jump into refereeing and letting go of
more rugby
um you know it was actually my wife
Vicky who said to me LOL what have you
got to lose like give it a crate give it
two or three years and see how it goes
and if it does doesn't go in the
direction that you want at all you're
not enjoying it then you can always go
back and play footy
um but I vividly remember that that
first game that under 12s game coming
off the field and like these young kids
coming up and just saying oh thanks so
much for such a good time and even
parents on the sideline saying thanks
very much
like that gave me a real sense of
contribution like I've made a difference
here
um it's a little bit different at the
professional level because now it's a
job you know you run out there and you
just do your job
um so that's why I actually really love
going back and you know referring
Community footy Club footy
um getting back to the like the true
Grassroots yeah
um you know going going back into the
club rooms afterwards and having a big
bot and talking to a few other Lads so
um yeah it's I think that's that's real
humbling too like it puts things in
perspective
um but yeah it is it is different now it
is challenging like this is a job
um you know
um but and saying that mate like what an
absolute privilege you know we get to be
involved
um as a for a job in the game that we
absolutely love and and we know our time
in the space is limited so yeah it's um
make the most of it while we can like
hey while the sun shines
so where do you get to a footy player
you mentioned yourself being a nippy
half back what sort of level did you get
to what held you back from being a pro
what held me back
um are you referring to more size here
not at all mate well size was probably
one of the size of D-Max
um I'd say well and that's yeah yeah
size is certainly one thing but I think
I was probably lacking in the skill
level as well yeah
um but now look
um oh yeah yeah just say the normal you
know New Zealand Young fella are
bringing played at four or five and had
a footy ball on my hand the whole way
through
um went away to University obviously um
yeah France Douglas played played first
15 there which he absolutely bloody
loved down to Varsity played down there
I was at um Palmerston North Massey
University oh yeah
um hell of a spot down there uh was back
in palmy just the other day and sort of
walked past the fits there are a few
good times that are there but um you
know from there I I went overseas and um
um picked up a sort of an amateur sort
of contract playing for a club in York
or playing for initially for a club in
Huddersfield oh yeah uh which is Big
League country that's that's up in the
north of England and uh myself and a
couple of other Lads that I was at Uni
worth we went over there and you know we
were just going for the experience mate
we just want to do a bit of traveling
see the other side of the world and you
know Rugby's this amazing tool that
we've got that allows us to have those
opportunities you know
so uh anyway he ended up um finishing up
with Huddersfield and we moved to
another club in York which was actually
York the the Rugby Club was York and
um you know my intentions were only ever
supposed to be to go over there maybe
for a season or two have a bit of an
experience come home and then you know
actually get into the real world you
know but I was having such a bloody good
time over there and the club that all
was worth uh it was an awesome bunch of
leads you know we were really well
supported uh they gave us a house they
gave us a car to get around and flicked
us a few match payments which are really
just beer tokens for the weekend mate
um but we were just living our best life
I it was so good and uh I I actually
during the summer time because
um obviously I need a little bit of work
to for a little bit more pocket money I
was working at the Rugby Club
um on the cricket pictures so it was a
rugby and Cricket Club yeah yeah and
they played in one level below county
cricket so it was a fairly handy
standard so my I was out on the roller I
was doing oh I was just living my best
life hey shorts and singlet on had the
headphones on you know you manage your
own time it was Bloody brilliant eh so
uh naturally I was pretty reluctant
about coming home and getting into the
real world but um yeah so I had three
very the best years of my life over
there but I ended up actually a funny
story though so I popped home for I
think it was a 21st or an engagement or
whatever it was and
um
I'd I'd use more two-year UK working
Visa so I knew that was gone so I
applied for a one-year Irish Visa I'm
not even too sure if they still these
visas still exist now but I wanted to
extend my stay so I did the one year
Irish one
and while I was on my one year or a Visa
I I came back home for this family
function when I flew back I flew back
with my little sister because she was
just starting her OE for the first time
and we came through came through customs
and everything was going pretty well you
know lined up yeah you get to the
scanning bit and um or remember the the
guy's face when he looked at my passport
and I knew straight away oh this isn't
good this is not good and
um he said excuse me sir can you just
move to the side so I moved to the side
and
uh I don't know 10 15 minutes later I
get taken into this room and
interrogated and all the rest of it
um interrogated it's probably not the
right word it was more just a discussion
but anyway they they had reason to
believe that it was overstaying
um like they were asking questions what
are you doing back here who's who's your
employer and all the rest of it and I
was just getting cashews from my my
Rugby Club you know so
it wasn't really legit so uh he had a
fair fair argument and um I remember my
sister was sitting next to me um because
she had to go through the process as
well but she was falling in the end and
this guy said to me hey look
um I'm not too sure which way this is
going to go
um either you'll be accepted and you'll
go through or there's a good chance that
you'll be on the next flight home
um so your sister you and your sister
sort of need to make a decision like if
she stays with you now there's a chance
she goes home as well
and as I turned to her to sort of like
start the discussion about you what are
we going to do here she was already
halfway out the door almost she was gone
just giving me a thumbs up from about
five meters away good luck bro so she
was off on her right we all staying here
in the interrogation room sort of uh
sweating Brooks and as it turned out
um or they took me to a Detention Center
which was sort of just off-site at
Heathrow Airport put me in a Paddy Wagon
took me there and all the rest of it
went through chicken sure yeah yeah it
got pretty gnarly pretty quickly and uh
at this Detention Center you know they
take everything off your phone that
works
so now I can't contact anyone
and uh even the people that sort of
checked me in were kind of looking at me
like with that look of what are you
doing here you know like and
like people in detention centers do not
look like a little white boys from part
here you know
um they're usually sort of uh looking a
little bit rough around the edges and
anyway we ended up um uh the sky and um
the sky takes me to my cell indeed it's
a dead set itself and I'm with another
guy from he he must be from G
I don't know Eastern European European
guy or something like that he was a big
sort of dark looking guy and a very
intimidating very intimidating
and um the cell door opens and um the
two of us are standing there side by
side and it's a bunk bed set up
and I don't know what possessed me to do
it but and you know what when you go on
school trips and stuff and you don't
want to get on the top bank so you just
got shocker so I just looked at him and
go shotgun and as I did it I was like
what are you doing then so anyway I
thought I got the best in of the deal
thinking you know that the safest place
for me in the cell was probably going to
be up high so I got up in this um top
bunk little did I know when the door
closed and locked they have a light in
the cell which stays on all night oh
true because in case someone tries to do
something they shouldn't you know which
probably worked out quite well for me
because I wanted to know where where
this other guy was
um but I did not get a wink of sleep
that night mind you I was only in there
for sort of four or three to four hours
and
um yeah I was on the plane back home to
New Zealand oh you came back
yeah so the Jokers I went all the way to
the UK for a soggy chicken salad
sandwich and then home again so oh your
sister made the right car yeah and she
had a great time and funnily enough
she's still living over there four times
then so yeah yeah it was a good move boy
here to stay on so that's why you came
back you were forced back I was force
back and the unfortunate thing with it
Jimmy was um I'd actually met my now
wife Vicky over there she's a Yorkshire
girl
um so she thought I was coming back the
Rugby Club thought I was coming back
um so I really felt as though I'd let a
lot of people down for this yeah and
um yeah she ended up staying on a little
bit longer
um but then she just obviously clearly
couldn't live without me you know so she
was like what a lovely man she was on a
floating back to New Zealand and
um you know I knew I really he had to
turn it on when she got back to New
Zealand so I had planned this like
Nationwide road trip you know I took
Urban far north I took her swimming with
the dolphins and she's like this is
awesome and I'm like yeah this is just a
typical weekend this is what we get up
to in New Zealand so yeah it's fair to
say I want her over there and uh yeah
we've now got uh three little kids
living in awakuta uh just south of New
Plymouth and living our best life mate I
mean it's like a movie so how long were
you together before you
um
that's a real good question probably um
the I I wouldn't know exactly when the
romance started so don't ask me how long
I've been together or married or
anything like that and put me on the
spot
um but it was fairly fairly soon after
getting to Yorke and that was probably
the reason why I ended up extending more
stay I mean don't get me wrong the rugby
and the layers were great yeah but it
was a little bit of an extra incentive
there as well
oh now it makes it yeah oh it's good so
it's a good yarn and you mentioned you
started playing footy when you were four
or five yeah but then you also I hear
that you had a pretty bad accident when
you were five so how did that sit check
your rugby career good and like to be
honest with you now that you say that
that's probably the reason why I didn't
become a man in Black oh yeah yeah so
when I was four years old um my dad was
in the farm Ute and actually ran me over
and I know that probably sounds pretty
full-on yeah it's not like he lined me
up from 10 meters out
got him that'll teach him to get out of
the way
um yeah it was just a bizarre set of
circumstances um
uh dad was in the care but you
um talking with um yeah Farm stuff
um next to him and I was on the back of
the tray reached around and said Dad I'm
getting off but he was in full
conversation mode he didn't hear yeah
and uh I climbed down off the back of
the Ute down onto the um tow ball and
then as soon as my foot hit the ground
he started backing up and uh yeah he
he's I mean it wasn't high speed or
anything but he slowly backed over me
and um
he he tells me he he remembers feeling
the bump and
um he thought it was just a bit of water
or something like that and as he backed
up and and then looked back in the
direction that he'd come from and
realized that I was lying there on the
ground
um you know he he said he was out of the
U that quickly that the Ute was still
rolling backwards as he was running
towards me yeah
um
and like it really shook him up eh it
really shook him up man as it would you
know and I'm even sort of visualizing
now if I was in that position and it was
my boy Jack you know
um yeah so as it turned out
um I I got rushed into our Farmhouse and
thankfully um one of my aunties was
there who's a nurse and she sort of cut
all my overalls off me and all the rest
of it and just said look
um he needs to get help straight away so
the closest help that we had was the the
vet group The the vet clinic and the
Heart here
um so mum and dad rushed me in there
took it to the vet oh sorry not the vet
the um the local the local doctor and
um but the the vet comes
uh took me to the doctor and the doctor
said um
yeah just just give them a bit of
paracetamol and put them to bed he just
needs a bit of rest and uh so mum and
dad didn't really know yeah they brought
me home what sort of pain were you in at
the time oh I was four I don't really
remember mate and you know I'm as hard
as Nails
I'd imagine it would have been pretty
bad where did the car actually run over
you so over my leg and over my
collarbone and was it both Wheels like
front and back yeah yeah
um so it was decent
um but anyway
um the the reason why I say about the
vet is because um you know I get back
home and my auntie who's the nurse is
just like oh my God you know
I wouldn't this is this is serious you
know like I wouldn't even send this
person to like I wouldn't even treat my
dog like this this is what I was sort of
getting at and uh so anyway I'm in the
car down to wanganui which is the
closest hospital at that stage um
yeah um as it turned out um yeah broken
leg um collarbone all the rest of it but
the the bit I like to to play up with
there is um every now and then you know
I'll be down at the the farm and um I'll
walk past them and just sort of put a
bit of a limp on and he'll ask me hey
what's up with you and I was like oh
just that injuries coming back to play
quick you know you remember when you ran
me over yeah yeah I just like to rub it
in a little bit so um but no no that was
um oh it's probably that's probably the
the only reason why I didn't make it
yeah that actually cost you like years
when you're playing were you nah not at
all mate I'm I'm four years old and my
ambitions are being involved by that
stage weren't really uh top of the
priority list but um like I was at Young
I don't really remember and you know
it's it's just part of being a kid you
know kids break arms and legs and stuff
all the time but um yeah I was Bloody
lucky mate I was Bloody lucky because if
the wheel had gone over another part of
the body it could have been a different
situation yeah yeah and hasn't stopped
to getting through 10K a game it hasn't
stopped me through getting tender
right yeah yeah my first memory of you
was
um when you refereed one it must have
been one of your earlier games it was a
taranaki Auckland preseason game
um in taranaki and it was I think it was
my first game as Captain it was one of
your first games as a as a referee and I
always remember
um just your mannerisms on the field I
felt like from that moment that I knew
you were going to be a a very good ref
and go through the ranks pretty quickly
and I think I even remember saying it in
the my first ever Captain's aftermath
speech but that is my first memory of
you as a as a person and as a referee oh
well that's um you don't remember it no
I don't I don't thought I changed your
life and inspired you well it would have
been nice to hear that but um you know
it's it's actually really really
interesting that say that because uh and
you said it before like the speed at
which
I progressed through the system was a
lot quicker than the normal pathway you
know
so I really battled for a long time with
imposter syndrome oh yeah
um you know it's not uncommon amongst um
you know Sports people that have been
accelerating everyone yeah yeah
um so yeah I battled for for quite some
time for to actually accept that you
know I was good enough to be there
um you know and and me being the kind of
guy I am I'm a massive introvert I like
um so that the spotlight is actually
something that is not comfortable for me
sure yeah yeah and it's yeah it may it
makes May strike you as surprising but
definitely like given the the job that I
do yeah but I remember doing um
some studies in positive psychology and
uh I had to do a personality sort of
survey and one of the things that fell
out of it was the fact that you know one
of my weaknesses was the spotlight and I
remember doing a sort of a review of my
personality survey with one of the
coaches
and I said riddle me this like I'm an
international referee I'm in the
spotlight weekend week out yet Spotlight
is one of my weaknesses help me out
understanding that
and she's like well okay we'll look at
your strings what one of your strengths
actually line up or maybe over put a
shadow over top of that um fear of or
not want to say fear but weakness of
Spotlight and it took me straight to
belief like as time went on I had a real
strong belief in
um my ability to to be a referee
sometimes it's too strong
and you know the fact that I can run out
there and go
physically I know I can do this mentally
I know I can do this you know I put a
lot of time into other areas of the game
around the tackle the breakdown of law
all that sort of stuff so it's all that
preparation piece you know like when you
know that you've done absolutely
everything that you can do
you have confidence to run out there and
do a good job I mean you need to accept
the fact that yep you will make mistakes
that we're human
um but I mean if you're running out
there with with any element of Doubt
then you're just setting yourself up for
failure you know
um so yeah that it really it really took
me some time in those first sort of two
or three years as a pro-referee to
actually accept that you know what I am
good enough to be here you know and do
you feel like you're playing not that
you played it in a professional level
but Semi-Pro level helped you progress
through the referee ranks quicker I feel
like you had that natural feel for the
game you understood yeah from a player's
perspective yeah yeah I I absolutely
think it was um it was an advantage and
I mean you can see that quite clearly in
the guys that have played at a
professional level that are now referees
you know the Nick Berry is a classic
example like while in the early stages
of his career like his law understanding
may not have been quite there hit an
amazing feel for the game and still does
have an amazing feel for the game and
now because of the time that he spent in
the game and the work that he's put in
behind the scenes around his law and all
the rest of it he's an outstanding
referee all around so absolutely I think
that would have helped
um but the big thing probably um is is
the relationship space you know like
um the relationships with with players
on the field is is really important
um you know accepting
um putting your hand up and being able
to accept that you have made a mistake
is really important as well which isn't
always easy especially when you come in
as a as a new referee
you want to show everyone that you're
good enough yeah you know you've got
this fear of like imposter syndrome
sitting over the top of you you're
making mistake oh I don't want to tell
anyone I made a mistake and it's kind of
like I don't know I guess I can only
speak on behalf of myself here but it
really feels as though the Journey's
Gone full circle
um you know I started off as a young
referee
um not really knowing too much very
naive but just loving the game and you
know making decisions that felt right
for me yeah then after a bit of time you
sort of get drawn into this refereeing
sort of Silo and you start seeing things
through like a referee perspective
and maybe you lose a bit of that game
understanding and game sense game
awareness and then you sort of come back
around again and you you start making
decisions that feel right for you you
know
um you know you have all that
understanding of the law you have the
understanding of the game you have the
sort of bigger um sort of worldly view
of of rugby and you know you're you're
quite happy to put your hand up and go
yeah I just made a mistake there or
um so that's definitely the place that I
feel that I'm in at the moment like
it's it's weird mate because the the
love I have for refereeing now is the
same love that I felt when I very first
started that under 12s game yeah I was
like this is awesome I love doing this
you know yeah
um and to compare like a frosty morning
star under 12s to the biggest stage in
the world which is a World Cup
um or you know running out on talking
them in front of 90 plus thousand having
that same feeling of love and enjoyment
and passion for the game
um yeah I really feel as I've gone full
circle on the side how good is that and
you mentioned you didn't you don't
really naturally like the spotlight talk
to me about your Instagram account the
new Paul Williams diary I'm I'm
fascinated by this I've seen it I feel
like yeah it probably took you a bit of
time to yeah yeah build up the carriage
to set this up but I think it's a good
thing yeah I guess like this is
something that's probably been brewing
for the last three to four years you
know like and as I said before you know
our time that we've got in this
environment is is limited so you know
how do we how do we really make the most
of it how do we how do we really like
squeeze the good juice out of it
um so you know again this again the
spotlight thing is not something that
I'm totally comfortable with so setting
this up was terrifying for me yeah
terrifying three years ago
yeah yeah
um you know even even doing like a
simple post where you're talking to your
phone to then post something that could
be seen by anyone
um you know is is really terrifying but
I mean
or there's a part of me that has a lot
of peace with that because if I know
it's terrifying it's taking me outside
my comfort zone yeah great and if I'm
outside my comfort zone you know that's
where the growth happens so strange way
of doing it but um anyway that's what
I'm doing and you know I've set it up as
um you know uh Paul Williams referee
diary 2023 particularly around you know
this is a pretty big year for referees
um but I thought it'd be cool to give
people a bit of an Insight of of the
referees world and actually you know
kind of show us show the world that you
know we're human it's not just the 80
minutes that you see the referee on the
field
how we deal with you know success how we
deal with
um failure if you want to call it
failure
um you know so there was definitely that
um sort of mindset around it but the
other part of it which has probably
become a lot more prevalent now
um was the whole sort of
um I guess idea of you know we're
getting we get a lot of negative
criticism
um and I'm not saying it's just us
players get it coaches get it you get it
mate
um so it's it's something that was
probably always going to be there
um but we're not set up my own personal
Instagram page Yanks ago yeah
um you know I was sharing my stuff with
my family I was there sharing stuff that
I do in my spare time and
then all of a sudden I was getting um uh
you know requests from people all over
the world to sort of follow me and you
know it started off with um you know
people that I'd met sort of in different
parts of the world and maybe shared a
beer with or whatever it may be
and then it started being people
um asking to um follow me that I'd never
met before but I could see they had sort
of some interest in rugby so I thought
you know maybe they're legit
and then it really dawned on me um when
I I did a post on my personal Instagram
page of my daughter when she was really
young she was she was running around
um a hotel room uh nude because
um we were celebrating the fact that
she'd just peed in the potty for the
first time you know like it was a
massive highlight in our world
um and then a good friend of mine um
Lauren Coleman she said to me like
um are you sure you should have posted
that and I I love laws she's a great um
a great woman and she's been almost like
a mother to us and the rugby referee
space
and um I sort of thought about it and I
was like
you know anyone anyone that follows me
now can see that post so the reason why
one of the other reason why I set up
this page was um my referee diary page
was to make a real clear separation
between well professional rugby life and
my personal life
um because you know more recently and
it's been very well publicized you know
um Wayne Barnes had a game
where he copped a lot of criticism which
wouldn't be foreign to him like we we've
sort of come become accustomed to that
now he's still copping up for that
forward pass years ago he was still
coughing it and I would definitely drop
it in conversation
um but you know then when his wife Polly
started getting targeted as well you
know that's where we need to draw the
line um you know it's it's our decision
that we do what we do in terms of
refereeing it's it's not their decision
so they shouldn't be the ones copying
this abuse
um so I was really proud of barnsey for
actually really voicing
um his concern and frustration and
disappointment and all the rest of it
because with the profile he's got and it
made traction you know and now all of a
sudden when we're getting this trolling
coming through they're actually being
the ones put in the spotlight in a
spotlight put on them going this is not
right you know versus them putting the
spotlight on us so
yeah three years there was method to the
madness but um and even now my all still
freely admit like I'm a little bit
reluctant about posting stuff but um you
know the feedback that I've had from
from people that follow it has actually
been really positive so that's that's
given me a little bit of confidence to
keep it going where do you see it going
forward do you see it like post game
would you ever review yourself or let's
say you had to make a big decision in a
game let's say the korabetti tackle
which you had to do yeah I think last
year would you use that platform as a
place to give your opinion or your
thoughts or how you felt it went or is
that sort of a bit of a No-No for a
referee well I think there's definitely
boundary lines that need to be upheld
yeah um you know I I'm employed by New
Zealand Rugby so I've got to be careful
in terms of you know what I broadcast
there
um I I'm also involved with World rugby
so again I've got
um boundary lines there so and also two
to the game like I've got to respect the
game but
I guess there's an opportunity there
again this is that this Human Side
coming out that when we have a game that
may not necessarily go that well I think
I want to be brave enough and to say you
know how I'm feeling about that game
um good or bad you know and and I think
that will really give people uh a really
good perspective on you know they're
more than just this robot that runs
around in the middle for 80 minutes
there's more to poor Williams than just
what you see in those 80 minutes
um so hopefully you know it might have
an impact on one or two people and if it
does and if it's a positive impact then
great I feel as I've made a contribution
and again it lines up with one of my
values
um so yeah there's
um I I do think it's a it's a vehicle to
help people understand you know the The
Wider picture of of a referee and I
guess the the risk of setting it up for
you is I guess it's an opportunity for
people to come at you yeah post a bad
game yeah yeah but um
you know yeah you did right and and I I
gave that a lot of thought when I set it
up but you know the the comments come
anyway whether it comes through a social
platform like that or you know people
find the time to track me down on
Facebook yeah and send it through
Messenger or whatever the the comments
come regardless so
um you know maybe it's an opportunity
for those that uh do follow the page to
actually see wow they they get these
sorts of comments you know so
um yeah look it hasn't come yet
um a bad comment the bad comments that's
good yeah um because you've been on fire
mate well and and again you know this is
this is the other thing about um that
maybe that slight apprehension about
projecting yourself out to the world too
much you know
um you know and even with the
20 or 30 followers I've got I'm not too
sure what it is you know
um it's it's not exactly like I've got a
Wayne Barnes profile or anything like
that but um yeah no I do see it as a as
an opportunity to you know portray
referees in a positive light yeah
definitely because you got you guys do
cop it so much I mean way more than
players way more than coaches you
mentioned before but
um I do feel like the referee is on the
end of it more often than not yeah but
I've got a great coach at home and my
wife she just gives it to me so I'm used
to it
the stuff for the 80 minutes after was
this nothing
um no no I I guess um yeah we do we do
mate there's no two ways about it we do
cop it um but again sort of I go back to
what
um I said right at the start if if you
have a real good understanding of
yourself and who you are
um all that external stuff
um you know it fades away yeah like yeah
it may sting for a little bit someone
may make it a harsh comment it'll sting
but just as long as it doesn't sink in
yeah yeah
um and it's really important in terms of
um you know looking after yourself and
you would have heard the analogy before
you know put your own oxygen mask on
first do what you need to do to look
after yourself
um and it'll put you in a real good
place to be able to deal with all that
crap you know yeah I think back to the
was it the South Africa game it must
have been like one or two years ago I
don't really remember the game I just
remember the
the criticism you you received after
that game how was how hard was that for
you there's been a few of them you
better narrow this down has it actually
like do you oh look it's it's different
what's been the worst game like what's
been the worst post game for you where
you really felt like oh man this is this
is rough well again it's it kind of
relates to age and Stage I remember
having a game age and Stage I like that
yeah
um so being a younger referee
um early on in my career uh odd a game
over in Canberra and as you know going
to Canberra for a super game it feels
like you're in another part of the world
and it was a bloody cold night I can't
remember exactly who the brumbies were
playing it's probably best I don't say
who it was so it'll probably narrow it
down but after the game I copped a lot
of criticism
a lot of criticism from fans social
media fans yeah yeah the works
um you know and at that time and again
my age and Stage I felt on the whole
world was implied and you know this
whole imposter syndrome that was just
revving up at full noise you know my the
voices in my head were saying you don't
belong here you're not good enough get
out of here
um and I remember one particular comment
that was made
um and I won't repeat it because not
only was it directed at me but it was
directed at the family and it was around
death
um
but yeah that really Shook Me Up
um but again because of the ages agent
stage
I didn't want to share that yeah I
didn't want to tell even my colleagues I
didn't want to show them oh look at this
guy who said this
um because of all those noises in my
head saying you're not good enough what
are you doing here
um so as time moved on and I guess fast
forward to where I am now when I got
that sort of criticism I'm like finding
that my first mate go Hey look check
this out look what he sent me uh and
having a laugh yeah not only having a
laugh like I'm also looking at it going
to the person who's taken the time to
track me down through social media or
whatever and write that
God I feel sorry for that person a they
must not have a lot of good going on in
their life for them to take the time to
do that you know so it's a weird thing
to say but I'm actually more concerned
about the person who's sending that than
than me on the receiving end yeah so I
think to fast forward and get into that
place it's a far better place to be you
know more often than not it's probably
someone who's had a massive punt more
than they get to and you're ready
that's right well I'm not a punter I
hadn't thought about that but you did
right but um so that was early on but
probably more recently there was um you
know that Cora bitty tackle and the
Aussie South Africa game
you know that was um that was a really
great occasion right up until that point
you know
um uh refereeing on the Adelaide oval
like wow you know I can say a refereed a
game on Adelaide oval
um but anyway it was um yeah Cory being
mad attack against one of the South
Africans and long story short
um you know it was a really Split
Decision in terms of
um what the right outcome was and
without going into the detail it pretty
much split two hemispheres you know like
um one hemisphere was saying you know it
should be this and the other hemisphere
is saying that and
I remember being caught in the middle of
it and I was just like
you know this is this is not really what
I signed up for you know yeah
um but in the same breath I'm like this
is all part of it and like we were
saying before like when it comes down to
those crunch games and the big
controversy and all the rest of it like
what a place to be yeah what a place to
be and again like a slock I've said
before
that what it builds in you as a human
and being able to control yourself in
that moment and deal with the aftermath
and you know you you need to be I guess
it's really refereeing has really helped
me grow up as a man
um probably not vertically up but still
waiting for that great sweat
um but uh you know just in terms of who
I am what I'm about what's important
what my priorities are you know what my
values are yeah you know so now when
sort of big stuff happens in the game
like you take it for what it is but it
doesn't Define you it doesn't like make
you a bad referee um doesn't make you a
bad person and I think too like again
age and Stage I've got a wife and young
family like I go home and Vicky doesn't
even really know where I've come from
sometimes and she's like where were you
referring this weekend you know the the
kids want to play and like Jack wants to
get into some Lego and Frankie wants me
to put some lemon makeup on or dress on
or whatever it might be be you know it's
just perspective right
rugby is great but gee it's just rugby
you know like yes it's it's a great game
and we get so wrapped up and all the
rest of it but sometimes we just need to
take a breath take a step back and go
you know there's more to life yeah
um yeah some people may not agree with
that but it's certainly how how I view
it at the moment and it certainly helps
me move on from those big moments yeah
man it's so true and it's such a good
mindset that you have and you take into
it I am intrigued and you spoke about
like the death threats yeah I am
intrigued to go into that a little bit
more and I have have you ever felt
really vulnerable or like physically or
with messages have you ever felt like
your safety was under threat being a
referee
um
there have been times coming off a game
when you're walking down through the
tunnel yeah and that's about as raw and
real as it gets yeah you know you get
the trolls that hide behind a screen and
a keyboard they're seeing your stuff
that stuff still stings
but when you've got people leaning over
hoardings
spitting spraying at you like that is
pretty intense
um so yeah a lot I can't narrow it down
like
and I think the game has moved on quite
some way from from that sort of behavior
um you know maybe I've just got lucky
and
um you know the games have gone well and
um you know I haven't caught that but um
the other the other tactic that I've got
as well mate is uh you just wait out on
the field for an extra sort of over 10
minutes talk to the players
a little bit
um but uh no no I don't think of
physically felt unsafe like we get
pretty well looked after
um you know on the ground border
security and all the rest of it but um
we've ever done the runoff sometimes you
see the rift just Sprint to that tunnel
no no I haven't done the runoff but it's
usually because I've got no energy left
in the leagues by that stage but um no I
yeah it's um
it's a real interesting one mate and
again it's it's what the pressure of the
environment does you know and again
again I come back to that fact that
if you don't have yourself in check you
and you cut and and you don't if you're
not able to manage yourself in those
moments then what hope do you have of
making good decisions in those moments
you know
um so yeah I you know I'm I'm really
really privileged and blessed
um to have been exposed to some great
people during my career
um particularly um Ted filbert Who's
down here in Christchurch who I I have a
lot of time and respect for and you know
he's done a lot of work with New Zealand
Rugby New Zealand Rugby referees and you
know what he's done for me
not only as a referee but as a man oh I
just oh I'm forever in his debt you know
um you know I'll still have a very very
close relationship with with him and
he's kind of like my my sounding board
you know he's my warrant of Fitness
chick
um I've also got a fantastic mental
skills coach in the in the form of um
Jace McKenzie you know again a really
well respected Sports psych
um so New Zealand Rugby is brilliant in
terms of putting that support around us
that we need and giving us the skills
that we need to be able to deal with
these moments you know
um because you know had I not had that
exposure I may not be sitting here now I
may not have made it this far you know
so no I'm I'm very very lucky but um you
know I think and particularly what those
guys have taught me when I first started
out and these guys were coming on I'm
like great this is going to be awesome
someone refereeing you know they're
going to make me a bit of referee but
we're actually better the better referee
part it was just a byproduct of actually
becoming a bit of human you know that
was their main focus I didn't know it at
the time
um I thought I just wanted to be a
better referee you know age and Stage
starting out in the career
but um you know what they've what
they've taught me and what they've
instilled in me
um you know has definitely made me a
better human a better father a better
husband I've been a mate you know so um
yeah I'm forever in their debt and what
are your plans as a referee going
forward you've obviously got the Rugby
World Cup this year to look forward to
you're confirmed into that no no no no
no uh those uh selections are made in
May so um yeah yep so we'll be uh
nervously waiting for a phone call
whether it be a a good one or how many
do they take we'll take 12 referees plus
a group of ARS in in tmos as well so you
know look um going to the the World Cup
in 2011 was um was a real highlight for
me and and that again it felt quite
sorry in 2019 the the World Cup in Japan
I got selected to go there and and
referee which was actually quite a um
when I was announced to go it was quite
a tough time because
um Glenn Jackson was what I felt our
number one referee in New Zealand at the
time and um you know it was for us as in
certainly a New Zealand group and
probably the world rugby referees as
well it was a it was a sure thing that
Jaco would be going and because I was
sort of still starting out in my career
and still quite young and naive and
vulnerable
um you know my ambition was just to get
there and go and hold a flag you know
and go and carry jacko's bags
um you know I've learned a hell of a lot
from the guy both on and off the field
probably primarily off the field to be
honest
um but you know when when he missed out
going there and I win as a referee
um I struggled with that I I did
struggle with that for a while because I
knew what the perception may be that um
you know how on Earth has Paul Williams
gone and and Glenn Jackson missed out
yeah
um and that didn't sit very comfortable
with me for a quite some time but I mean
a certain I'm saying this now it
certainly wasn't a case of me being
better than him because I certainly
wasn't he was definitely a number one
referee certainly what I felt at the
time but you know they they try and
bring some younger stock into the World
Cup refereeing ranks having some
experienced guys there because
um you know when those experienced guys
move on we can't all of a sudden then
just have a whole new cup of new guys
coming into a world cup so there was
certainly some a bit of a political
agenda behind it
um but still it didn't sit well with me
I even remember ringing dad
and telling him and he was shocked to
know that Jaco wasn't going he's like
what so they've put you over Jeffco
yeah thanks Dad
um that's when you know you know if you
want the truth you go and get it from
the old man
um but yeah that was that was pretty
tough
um but you know yeah like like I say
like selections for the swirl cup
um in in France will be made in May
um and yeah absolutely I'd love to be
there you know but I'm also aware that
I'm amongst some great referees here in
New Zealand some great referees
worldwide
um I am aware that sometimes you can be
refereeing the absolute house down yeah
and it doesn't work out for you and
Jacko is a classic example of that
um but I mean like I said before like
I'm really at a place now where
um I'm just loving my Rugby
um you know if I do if I do go then
fantastic awesome well I can't wait to
be amongst the the biggest spectacle in
the Rugby World
um but equally if I'm not there
um yep it'll hurt I'll be disappointed
no doubt because I've been working
bloody hard for it yeah
um but you know I always accepting of
the fact as well so yeah
but I'll hope it's the letter surely
surely it's the letter the form you're
in mate you're the first picked maybe
behind barnsie would you say Barnes is
the best oh referee in the world
absolutely yeah yeah and and it's not
just for his um you know his his
technical ability on the field you know
he's been doing it for such a long time
yeah there's game understanding his game
under awareness like I said before
relationships yeah like that guy is just
phenomenal in terms of building rapport
with people
um but it's also the work that it does
away from the 80 minutes on the field
you know
um what he does for our group our world
rugby referees group
um and the way he sort of leads us is I
guess he kind of call him the kaimatua
of the yeah of the um the world rugby
referees group so
um I have a hang of a lot of respect for
him I and you know I I really hope that
um the World Cup sort of goes his way
um because he he really deserves to to
get that Pinnacle game you know before
well that was one of the questions we
have had about a thousand questions
coming for you referee or referees
always seem to get plenty of questions
coming we'll we'll erase her a few of
these
um you've answered a lot of them to be
fair
um this one who is the worst slash
grubbiest player to referee James
Marshall
no uh of I've been pretty lucky I
haven't had too many um guys that uh
they've sort of rubbed me up the wrong
way too much but um
you know there's some hellishly strong
competitors out there right like you
don't need to go too far past the likes
of TJ yeah you know he's constantly Got
You Under the pump so
um yeah now and and a game make the the
game that we play we don't get the grubs
anymore
um you know it's you usually get that
when you go back to club club rugby land
yeah
um so now I've been pretty fortunate I
might have haven't really had too many
or none that spring to mind anyway I've
been TJ yeah
he's going good okay uh are there any
riffs in the other sports that you
admire do you watch many riffs and other
codes or
um to be honest with you I don't you
know
um there's there's that much more in
rugby on at the moment and um
you know there's not a lot of spare time
in the day and when I do have that spare
time it's usually wrapped up around kids
and what's going on in their world like
our TV we um we moved it in our Lounge
um about four or five months ago just to
sort of reposition it we actually
haven't plugged it back in yet sure yeah
yeah so you know I'm working during the
day
and uh you know I really want to
prioritize that time I have uh in the
morning and the evening for the kids you
know today
um so when you're living in Paradise
where you can just jump across the road
go for a surf on the beach that's the
one I'd love to say I'll surf but um no
I'm not a surfer I'm not a fisherman I'm
not a mountain climber which is actually
quite bloody poor really when you think
about it sandcastles that's all onto at
the moment but when you're watching a
game of sport
um you're watching the players you're
not watching the referee you're not the
vet
um someone asked me this yesterday
actually like who do I who do I watch
and um I think it's a combination of
both now
um you know naturally you you're
watching what the referee is doing
because it's it's um you know part of my
job and who I am
um but I'm I'm still that guy who loves
the game loves sitting back on the couch
and just appreciating two teams that
play phenomenal footage you know I think
the other things as well like now that
I'm a referee I don't have
um uh I mean now obviously one with the
Crusaders but before then I hadn't had
an alliance with any team so I wasn't
supporting that team or that team so
but funny story on there obviously now
that I'm involved uh you know with the
Crusaders and
um you know what a privilege that is to
be able to come down here in the
environment uh learn for some learn from
some fantastic coaches talk to the
players
um you know it's really helping grow my
game and uh yeah I really hope that I'm
able to sort of contribute back as well
um but uh no I remember
um we wasn't I was I was watching
watching a game and um
I know mine's gone and mine's gone
I can't remember what I was going to say
there
yeah Union Union no no different sport
no no
forget it oh that's right I'm back yes
he's back I'm back uh we were I just
referred a game in Hamilton
um this was earlier the season and um it
was The Crusaders Blues game this is it
it's coming back now yeah Crusaders
Blues game we were in um the helm I
think it is the Helmand in Hamilton yeah
yeah a bar in the middle of town there
and either guys that I was refereeing
with um on the Chiefs game and we
finished up and we came back to the helm
for a for a meal and a couple of quotes
and the the Crusaders Blues game was was
on the TV and um Brendan pickerel my
colleague who is with the blues like
it's his franchise team yeah
um I put a small wager on it with them
and um
I'll tell I'll get to the wager in a
minute but uh sounds big now now all of
a sudden there was something on it you
know it was his team against my team
yeah so here I was in the middle of
Hamilton in this bar we know the game
was swimming down to the wire and I was
just come on boys come on
um you know so all of a sudden like I've
got these eyes looking at me going who
is this Muppet from Christchurch who's
that no you know
um that no he was a referee they're
wondering why is he supporting the
cruise yeah it probably was a little bit
strange but um you know the great thing
about it is like I have no involvement
with the Crusaders on a game yeah you
know and that's super super important
for everyone to understand
um but now it's a chance for me to
actually help give back to um well I
want to say give back it's not that big
a deal but you know I get to make a
contribution within a team and as a and
as a byproduct of there I get to absorb
all this great information resources
from the likes yourselves the players
you know they're asking fantastic
questions about the game which has now
got me thinking yeah so it's just
expanding me and growing me as a referee
so it's a really really good
relationship and a great initiative that
was set up by Chris Pollock um and um
the high performance unit at New Zealand
Rugby so yeah there's there's only been
positives to come out of it but anyway
the wager
The Wager was I said to bring and pick
her all like look if um if your boys won
then I'll go and buy a blues cap and
I'll wear it on our Review called our
Zoom call so this is the call that all
the referees sit on yeah management and
all the rest of it oh we're a blues cap
and
um but if I win if the Crusaders win
you've got to do the same I said you're
up for it and he's like yep I'm up for
it hence why there was so much
excitement I was getting up and fist
pumping more so knowing the fact that he
was going to sit there with a blue skiff
on so I had so much pleasure and jumping
on that Zoom call on Tuesday morning to
see him sitting there he didn't he
didn't buy a blues cap but Crusaders
wasn't it I'm sorry Crusaders he didn't
buy Crusaders cap he said uh he couldn't
find one anywhere you're kidding which I
think is an absolute cop-out yeah but
what he did do was he changed his
background to the Crusaders logo oh okay
so I was like okay I'll give you that
you've made it you've made half an
effort there so um yeah I'm looking
forward to the rematch yeah later but
the Crusade has made no money from him
at least
40 hits you're right you're right yeah
no I'll hold on to that okay next one
what happened to Chris gaffney's Jet Ski
oh okay here's a reference he's an
Umpire Cricket employer best in New
Zealand
um so we hit a Super Rugby Camp
um the New Zealand guys uh pre-super
rugby this year down in Queenstown and
um we did a bit of tiki touring around
the place and we ended up doing a bit of
team building stuff in Wanaka within It
Was Then followed up by
um a presentation done by Tony brown
brownie and uh Chris Gaffney so they
just sort of opened up about their world
as an
Umpire and cricket and a coach in rugby
and afterwards we wrapped up and we were
in the local Rugby Club and we had a
couple of quiets and they said oh why
don't you guys come down to the lake
we've got a couple of jet skis you can
come down have a home and naturally we
were like yes please we'll be all over
that yeah so down we go and um the few
of the boys shoot out on the jet ski and
they've had a bit of a beforehand
they've had a little bit of a um I guess
a
what to do and what not to do and all
the rest of it um anyway I went down a
little bit later and had a go and
honed off and came back into the shore
and I didn't get the instructions So and
I've never driven a jet ski before so
I'm just kind of winging it a little bit
yeah and I just thought okay I'll just
gently come into the shore and it's it's
Stones you know and the lake it's it's
not sand
um so I'll just gently cruise into the
shore here and I'm sure those that have
used the jet ski and Nabi ajitsukis know
where the story is about to go
but Brownie's standing sort of out ankle
deep on the shore and he's looking at me
and I'm looking at him and he's looking
at me and I'm looking at him and I'm
just slowly cruising him
and he just says kill it and I'm like
okay I don't know how to kill it it's
like kill it now I'm like I I don't know
here and then as I'm getting closer I
can hear the stones starting to get
sucked up through the motor and he can
hear it as well
and he just goes kill it so I'll rip
this cord out off uh off the thing the
engine shuts down and he looks at me and
he's just shaking his head oh my
goodness
and he came over and had a look and um
I said to him is it bad and he just he
didn't say a word he just looked at me
and nodded and I was like oh God and
then he kept walking around and he said
ah it's okay and I said what do you mean
he said it's gaffney's one it's not much
so he's a bit of a running joke there on
on the guy who bloody ruined Chris
gaffney's Jet Ski so oh brutal it is
brutal but I learned a harshness in that
day but there was no hiding I just had
to put my hand up and acknowledge the
up so yeah yeah and that's one
thing you do well yeah agent stage yeah
agent stage you did right yeah yeah okay
next one what's the most embarrassing
moment of your refereeing career today
um look there's probably been little
moments on the field where you kind of
go oh it's embarrassing but I don't
think I've had too many like broadcast
like howlers you know um or broadcast
sort of mishaps where I'm I'm really
embarrassed but you know we get bumped
over from players from time to time and
like even the
Fiji Enduro against the um Highlanders
down in Dunedin a few weeks back I got
cleaned up two or three times you know
um
thankfully I'll bounce pretty quickly
you know let's back up on my feet and
away we went but uh or is uh as I'm
thinking now I vividly remember and
again early on in my career very naive
there was a pre-season game
North Harbor was might have been playing
Auckland at one of the club grounds up
there
so I was very low key but Jay um
uh James Parsons was was the hooker yeah
and obviously we know who James Parsons
is and I knew who James Parsons was
um but putting down the scrum no it was
before the game I was chatting to him
and I said um
looks at me and then out on the field
what sort of Sam can you just do that
and he's like
okay he's looking at me strangely again
and um I must have well I've done this
like three or four times now
and um I called him Sam one more time
and he just looked at me and goes it's
James
and I was like oh my God so I played
rugby a lot of Club rugby with a guy
called Sam Parsons so it was locked in
my head sandpass and Sam pass and so
I'll be calling James pass and Sam for
like the last 40 minutes of this game
and he's just looking at me going what a
muppet and then when he said to me mate
it's James I was just like oh you talk
so thankfully pre-season not too much
heat on not too many people knew but I
was so embarrassed so yeah you know is
that why referees usually use numbers
instead yeah yeah when we forget names
we just uh captain or number
um and some of the names are actually
pretty tricky these days yeah you've got
to be careful there you do you do indeed
okay next one did Elliot Dixon ground
the ball in the 2015 final yours please
hey um you know we're all about awarding
tries oh yeah we'd love to see a try get
in there blow the whistle get out of
there and if we've completely got wrong
then hopefully the team I can save us
um hey look yeah give it a try yeah why
not fair enough yeah right a water yeah
okay how many press-ups can you do
what right now oh I'm not now but no
um just pretend you were about to do
them right now you're oh yeah
actually there was a time not not too
many seasons ago where we were doing
this as a group of referees just um
stupidly but oh yeah stupidly before a
game
which is not that great what like a Max
presser yeah because yeah the tml
attaches and you just go to go to fail I
think it would have been myself James
dolman O'Keefe maybe the team I opted
out of that gym session but uh I think
we got up around sort of the 50s or 60s
yeah don't yeah it was a couple of years
ago probably not the same there pound
for pound must be one of the strongest
okay next one thoughts on the lower
tackle height roll this is an
interesting one yeah it is
um you know I totally understand where
where the games going around you know
player safety and and that being
Paramount it always is the case
um you know I do think that uh
we need to apply a little bit of common
sense though as well
um you know I was chatting with um a
group of my local referees
and um we were kind of just discussing
you know how how are we going to
adjudicate this and particularly Club
rugby land and um you know we spoke
about the the kind of tackles where
guys are running off the line you know
it's high speed it's high impact when
those guys are tackling high like that's
a No-No like they've got time and space
to be able to make a better decision
there
um I think we need to apply a little bit
of common senses you know where the the
impact's lower the the level of danger
is lower and yes while the tackle might
be high like let's say someone's at the
base of Iraq they pick and go they're
naturally going to be ducking low anyway
you know so it then becomes extremely
difficult for a Defender to go even
lower right
he does bring Des Moines lead with a hip
lead with the head
um but uh so in those moments we need to
be good enough to apply some common
sense and like we said earlier around
you know having that game understanding
that's really really important you know
because if we just go black and white
anything that's above
um nipple line or whatever it is
um as a penalty or whatever I think
we're actually doing a disservice to the
game
um and you know
we have a responsibility like our time
as referees in the middle we we become
ambassadors for the game like we've got
a real sense of Duty to and care to look
after the game and whole you know
um so it's important that we are making
decisions that people understand and and
primarily the players understand
um yeah yeah that's probably what I'd
say around that at the moment fair
enough I like that answer that's a good
one okay two more
as a non-happy Gilmore lover why haven't
you Incorporated more of his quotes into
your referee that's a I think I know
where that question has come from too
who
I think it might be Brad Weber yeah
right look alike actually and similar
yeah what do you reckon I was just
thinking at the end I don't know who
should be more offended there
um no the fact that you don't know shows
your house
[Laughter]
now I've got a Haver respect for bread
he's a good man he's an absolute Legend
um and I can't remember exactly word for
word what the what the quote was that um
he said during the game but uh now all
of a sudden we've kind of started this
little tradition that when we when we're
in the same game together
um someone will pull out a Happy Gilmore
quote and uh hope that the other one
perks up on it but obviously you've got
to be quite careful about that if it's
the dying stages of a game and it's all
drawn up he's not really interested in
the heavy Gilmore quote you know
um yeah yeah but no I I'm not too sure
when I've got the Chiefs next but I
wanted to work on a little bit more uh
more fodder for that yeah I'll have the
rest um audio on for that game I'll try
and pick it up myself uh it's good stuff
okay last question ask everyone this one
best piece of advice you have for a
woodland listener
best piece of advice for a water lead
listener
um
yeah I don't want to go too deep on this
one but it go as deep as you need
um
Embrace every moment
um and and the reason why I say that is
it doesn't just apply for for us as
referees or us as coaches or rugby
players or Sports people whatever
that applies for everyone because in
terms of the stuff that we can control
the only thing we can control is what's
happening right now
we can't control about what's happened
we can't control what's about to happen
what's coming up all we can do is
control right now in this present moment
like the fact that you and I are sitting
here right now this is all we can
control nothing else is in our control
at the moment so embrace the here and
there is what I would say to you what
led listeners wow that is impressive
I've definitely got you at the perfect
age and Stage to get you on this podcast
because man this has been something
special thanks mate mate it's been an
absolute pleasure being here mate really
appreciate you giving up your time
you're a legend of the game you're one
of the best referees in the world really
looking forward to
following a journey from here obviously
it's been awesome having you part of the
Crusaders and learning as much as I can
off you but
um yeah really looking forward to the
end of the year seeing you at the World
Cup and referring some of the biggest
games following the rugby referee diary
2023 and if you are listening to this
make sure you go give it a follow
there's plenty of good stuff on there
and
um yeah really appreciate you giving up
your time and coming on the water Lab
podcast thanks mate absolute pleasure
you're a lad
[Music]
absolutely
[Applause]
[Music]